I believe that Donald Trump is a
terrorist who committed horrific acts
I'm off the grid for August but fear not
CNN is still a far left activist
organization pretending to be a
journalistic outfit when I first learned
about the indictment
um I had a long conversation with a
friend of mine Ryan Riley and I told him
how proud I felt
to be an American at that moment much in
the way that I did when I learned that
our military had killed Osama Bin Laden
um I just felt
incredibly proud these two seem
comfortably proud to have been I'm sorry
I want to cut you off but the why why
are that why that comparison in
particular
I believe they're comparable
in what way absolutely
uh Osama Bin Laden was a terrorist who
committed a horrific act against
American people and against our Republic
and I believe that Donald Trump is a
terrorist who committed horrific acts
against the American people
you can imagine that that is a very
eyebrow raising statement to say the
least the notion of Osama bin Laden in
comparison to Donald Trump it likely
speaks to just How Deeply you have been
concerned and have felt about all of
this but are you concerned that
statements like that or the rhetoric
surrounding what his role has been is
going to cloud people's view of this
indictment as a fair process
I think that the only person or people
whose view matters with regards to this
indictment are the jurors who will
eventually be sat and listened to the
facts
um and ultimately make a judgment as to
whether or not Donald Trump is guilty of
the charges that Jack Smith in the
Department of Justice have brought
forward
foreign